you say cyrus est bienvenu dans le coup
de fil l'autre jour je pensais à l'état
de nature
c'est la situation dans laquelle on se
serait trouvée avant l'émergence de la
société et je veux demander à quoi ça
pourrait ressembler ou non aucun doute
et en fait ça aurait été vraiment pour y
voir juste impossible
tout simplement parce qu'il nous faut
des règles ok pour les règles mais pas
plus d'une fois par mois mais avec les
règles est ce qu'on perd pas un petit
peu notre liberté naturelle
bah si du coup il nous faut une nouvelle
liberté et ça c'est rousseau qui nous le
dit dans le contrat social de rousseau
où sont donc philosophes des lumières
qui est génial les gars super super la
mer bref o'bosso il a écrit du contrat
social et dans son livre il réfléchit à
comment imposer d'une manière légitime
une autorité un peuple
mais est-ce que c'est pas une fausse
question à schaffhouse
j'avoue les gars c'est une fausse
question en fait genre ressources à un
bateau et nous embrouiller tousser ou
pourquoi c'est une fausse question en
fait j'ai pas compris son show puisque
rousseau se rend compte que le peuple
n'existe pas sans autorité sinon ce
serait qu'un simple regroupement
d'individus et non un peuple
donc si le peuple n'existe pas sans
autorité c'est à dire que dès qu'on
parle de peuple
ils les autorités et donc c'est
l'autorité qui permet aux peuples
existent et donc on sort d'une
opposition entre peuples autorités et
ouais mon gars et ouais merci de m'avoir
choisi de m'avoir élu et j'exercerai mon
autorité avec le plus de loyauté
possible merci et vive nous pourquoi ça
ne marche pas juste excuse moi en fait
l'ac marche pas parce que
t'as pas de peuple en fait ah ça c'est
ça c'est pour le savoir à savoir la c1
personnelle unique pour comprendre d'où
viennent se peuplent cette autorité pour
retourner à l'état de nature à l'état de
nature les hommes s'embrouille et donc
ils doivent s'associer pour survivre ok
pour trouver une forme d'association qui
nous permet de vivre en société
pas de soucis mais cette forme on doit
se sentir libre et on doit y être
protégé oui parce qu'a priori ça pas
toujours ensemble
je peux te mettre dans une cage tu seras
super protégés mais tu seras pas du tout
et al'inverse tu peux avoir toute la
liberté du monde
et toi pas tenir cinq minutes d'ailleurs
y en a un qui a quitté le contrat social
c'est le mexique taux de wilde et on a
vu ce que ça a donné
le mec il a fini par se geler les
coucougnettes dans un van au fin fond de
l'alaska
oh
alors que d'en contracter libre et
protéger et c'est pour ça que le contrat
il est double je m'engage moi même
envers la société et par conséquent je
me place sous son autorité et en échange
la société s'engage envers moi et mof
plus de liberté et plus de sécurité mais
pas belle la vie deux ans après avoir
signé son contrat social jean-marcel
centralisons donc la société n'a pas
respecté ses engagements
non non la société n'a respecté aucun
engagement qu'elle est avec moi
notamment sur la propriété en gros ma
propriété doit être protégé par la
société si quelqu'un voulait finir me
prendre un bien la société qui fait du
fer elle est où la société
oui la société c'est pour ça que le lien
entre souverains et peuple il est
réciproque et doublent chaque individu
devient citoyen et participe à
l'autorité souveraine en votant par
exemple et en même temps il est sujet
car il est soumis au loin excusez moi
est-ce que c'est ici la soirée son
ambition enfin dans la démocratie en
tout cas pas dans les régimes qui
utilise la force et ça c'est très lié au
fait que l'expression droit du plus fort
bah ça n'a pas de sens soit c'est un
oxymore
c'est comme morts-vivants clair obscur
réalité virtuelle
bah oui le droit ça appartient à la
morale tu le suis volontairement alors
que la force pas du tout et c'est pour
ça que tu n'as pas ce sentiment de
citoyenneté
quand tu obéis à la force cliquer ici
pour une vidéo bonus sur les conditions
à respecter pour entrer dans contrat
social au fait j'ai pas réussi à le
caser correctement mais je veux juste
vous dire que pour rosso la première
société c'est la famille donc soyez
gentils avec vos mamans et si vous aussi
vous avez l'impression que parfois en
dessous de notre gueule dans le contrat
social actuel n'hésitez pas à dire ce
que vous pensez dans les commentaires
en tout cas j'espère que le contrat
social est maintenant plus là pour toi
et n'oublie pas de la même façon que
sans peuple il n'y a pas d'autorité sans
toi il n'y a pas de coups de films
en attendant on se retrouve pour un
prochain épisode du coup de fil d'ici là
du l'homme et de la peace cup et du fin
fond de l'ontario je vous présente jean
jacques rousseau